mais d'abord le polémiste devenu
candidat eric zemmour veut redonner du
souffle à sa campagne fabien becker
voilà c'est un message de dix minutes
adressé aux français qui vient mettre
fin à des mois de faux suspense il
n'écoute aux réformes et la france mais
de là souvent c'est pourquoi j'ai décidé
de me présenter
élection présidentielle dans une mise en
scène qui copient l'appel du 18 juin du
général de gaulle eric zemmour dresse le
tableau d'une france qu'il dit en déclin
ou saintes et étrangers dans votre
propre vous êtes des exilés de
l'intérieur la vidéo enchaîne les images
de violences urbaines les références à
une histoire glorieuse et les attaques
contre les élites dénoncé comme coupable
pour mieux permettre aux polémistes de
se poser en sauveur chaque fois qu'il
parle d'une institution paul ellis
hôpitaux etc on voit des faits divers en
face les urgences envahi par quelqu'un
qui est violent les commissario pris
d'assaut et zita donc c'est toujours
anxiogène après vous avoir montré une
réalité horrible tout ce qui va pas en
2021 on va vous montrer la france
d'avant c'est un clip très brillant dont
le registre populiste yetu ya mec french
do it again il fait du trump ya la
nostalgie à la promesse de rétablir la
france comme elle était avant après la
séquence de marseille qui était
particulièrement mauvaise et la séquence
du doigt d'honneur il se
représidentialise tient reste à savoir
si cette vidéo aux accents populistes
saura convaincre l'électorat de droite
que visent eric zemmour le désormais
candidat va maintenant pouvoir se lancer
dans la course aux 500 parrainages et on
analyse cette entrée en campagne avec
mes invités chloé ridel bonsoir
bienvenue est directrice adjointe de
l'institut rousseau fait lyrique
d'amibes ont soif on soit revenu à vous
aussi directeur général du département
opinion de l'ifop alexandre ii vecchio
bonsoir cendres éditorialiste politique
rédacteur en chef adjoint des pages et
des bas du figaro en charge du figaro
boxe c'est sûr que ça ce que je voulais
dire politique c'est plutôt les dix
siècles pas ça peut m'arriver de sauter
une ligne pardon
les rappels et issac votre livre la
tentation du clown qui a publié aux
éditions buchet chastel est consacrée
entre autres à eric zemmour et à tous
ses prédécesseurs
étrangers jouent demandent une analyse
générale sur cette vidéo on va parler
évidemment de du bug de certaines images
qui n'ont pas été dans les droits n'ont
pas été on va dire acheté par l'équipe
d'eric zemmour mais je voudrais que vous
mettiez ça de côté un instant pour une
première analyse un peu un peu général
sur la forme et comment vous l'avez
est-ce que vous avez été surpris si un
peu et ridha ben moi j'ai surtout
l'impression d'une très mauvaise pièce
de théâtre en fête après des mois de
faux suspense sur sa candidature il
annonce sa candidature dans une sorte de
mise en scène qui est censé faire
référence à l'appel du 18 juin 40 comme
si la france était envahie par les
allemands au bord de la guerre enfin
tout ça est un peu grotesque et on a
compris son message son message c'est la
france va disparaître nous sommes des
exilés dans notre propre pays enfin tout
cela est complètement délirant mais on a
quand même du mal à voir quel est son
projet pour la france il montre des
images de 19 ans de belmondo on les
adore c'est à dire c'est pas la question
mais c'est quoi il faut ressusciter
belmondo il faut revenir au film noir et
blanc j'ai on voit pas vraiment quel est
son projet pour la france il parle de
refaire des français de retrouver le
sens de la république etc ça parlons-en
s'éteindrait sujet mais qu'est ce qu'ils
proposent pour ça est ce que il propose
de s'attaquer aux ghettos scolaires à la
ségrégation spatiale dans notre pays non
il n'en parle pas et quand il parle
d'éducation il a toujours les mêmes
lubie qui reviennent du style on
inculque à nos enfants une idéologie
lgbt enfin tout ça est délirant et n'est
absolument pas à la hauteur des enjeux
et c'est ce que les français attendent
alexandre ii vêtue à sion l'aï trouvée
efficace et ben oui très efficace je
dois dire que j'ai été très critique sur
le les dernières semaines de campagne
notamment l'épisode marseillais et là je
trouve que c'est efficace parce que je
crois que le but est pas de dérouler un
programme de campagne mais de faire
échos
angoisse existentielle des français est
effectivement tout y est alors certains
trouveront ça apocalyptique mais je
crois que dans une partie de la
population ceux qui sont tentés par un
vote radical ça parle en plus il le fait
plutôt subtilement puisqu'il n'ya pas
les mots clés ya pas islamiste ya pas
immigration mais tout le monde a compris
ça c'est l'une des parties que j'ai
trouvé efficace que j'ai trouvé
également efficace et qu'il il exalte
une certaine fierté française il exalte
l'histoire de france il a des références
littéraires et justement ça lui permet
de sortir du côté apocalyptique et de
donner un peu d'espoir c'est le côté 30
pistes great america
faire la france grande dune joue en
quelque sorte et de ce point de vue là
c'est efficace et enfin c'est efficace
tout simplement masquer le débat des
républicains ce soir et d'une certaine
manière ils les ringardises d'ailleurs
personne n'en parle la forme quand même
extrêmement nouvelle
raphaël lorca parlait de n'être
liquidation de la vie politique on était
rentrés dans l'ère netflix il ya il ya
un peu de ça et on se dit que le dédain
explique dans cette vidéo une version un
peu plus amateur mais dans la manière de
faire campagne avec des rebondissements
sans cesse 2 0 on a l'impression d'être
dans une série télévisée alors que le
débat puisse apparaître plutôt comme un
vieux feuilleton de tf1 des années 90 a
bien qui sort du chapeau et ça c'est
pour la fin de la semaine chez les
républicains sheller frédéric dabi à qui
s'adresse jeu reprend une partie de la
démonstration de d'alexandre ii vêtue à
qui s'adresse eric zemmour avec cette
vidéo ils adressent envie de dire à tous
les français dans nos enquêtes on a vu
que le constat sur le déclin sous la
france qui tombe sur la perte d'identité
est majoritaire dans le dans le pays il
est structurant comme jamais avant une
élection présidentielle même s'ils n'y a
pas que ça il ya aussi des français qui
trouvent que la france a beaucoup
d'atouts qu'elle peut bien sûr rebondir
qu'elle n'est pas foutu si je puis dire
non ce qui est très intéressant c'est
une véritable continuité entre sa
vraie-fausse pré campagne et cette
déclaration de candidature c'est à dire
la rupture la distinction vous ne posiez
desquels vous poser une question sur la
forme si on reste sur la forme on
absolument jamais vu ça une déclaration
de candidature en musique avec la
septième de betteraves le deuxième
mouvement moi je vois -
charles-de-gaulle que le discours d'un
roi ou georges six appels à la
mobilisation des anglais contre une
invasion prochaine des affaires de la
wehrmacht il ya la pénombre il ya le
fait qu'ils lisent ces feuilles le micro
il ya le tragique et donc ce ton
complètement inédit est en rupture avec
toute une série même venant de jean
marie le pen qui a souvent annoncé comme
nature sur le mode apocalyptique la
bande des quatre la france va tomber
c'est encore plus poussée et c'est il ya
une vraie adéquation entre cette forme
dramatique tout en étant calme parce que
la septième de méthode le deuxième
mouvement est un mouvement lent est un
mouvement extrêmement calme et qui
annonce la tempête le troisième
mouvement dans ce cadre là le fonds est
en adéquation avec la forme le fond
c'est la france qui tombe le déclin avec
cette anna fort pour retrouver le pays
de le pays de 2,2 de voltaire
monter ce que tout ce qu'il a dit nania
pas si tu es monté ce que je pense tout
ce qu'il a dit et puis après une autre
un accord avec c'est pourquoi c'est vrai
qu'il est resté sur le constat il est
resté sur cassandre alors c'est vrai
qu'il y aura plusieurs temps on verra si
ça ce soir ou demain telle est visé de
tf1 devant gilles bouleau mais c'est
vrai que les propositions au-delà du
constat sont pour l'instant complètement
absente et les français ne lisent jamais
ni caton ni cassandre mais les tiac
repas il fait le choix d des réseaux
sociaux pourquoi il fait le choix de la
notation moody alors qu'est déjà dire
expliquer pourquoi effectivement et
choisit youtube parce que effectivement
on pouvait avoir cette déclaration de 10
minutes sur tous ces réseaux mais c'est
sur sa plateforme youtube pourquoi parce
que vous l'avez dit fredericks et
transgressif disruptif à dire est
manuelle macron c'est à dire que c'est
la première fois qu'un candidat fait ça
et pourquoi c'est la première fois qu'un
candidat fait cela parce que eric
zemmour depuis le début se présente
comme un apolitique comme un candidat
qui n'est pas politique qui ne vient pas
du monde de la politique comme un
candidat hors système donc c'est le
meilleur support ça c'est très cohérent
dans sa stratégie de communication
et ensuite il choisit youtube aussi
parce que c'est un média qui capte
l'attention et qui distribue les vidéos
en fonction de la durée
ce sont à quel de la durée avec laquelle
vous restez vous regardez la vidéo est à
dire que la durée de visionnage c'est à
dire plus vous regardez la vidéo plus la
vidéo a de chances d'être envoyé à jean
sérien votre soeur votre femme votre ami
qu est donc c'est effectivement la
violence qui permet de capter
l'attention du public or dans cette
déclaration d'eric zemmour il ya de la
violence symbolique dans les mots à
chaque phrase est de la violence dans
les images une image sur trois est une
image de violence donc il sait
pertinemment qu'il s'adresse à sa base
bien sûr à ses électeurs mais aussi à
tous ceux qui ne sont pas captif des
médias traditionnels parce que j'entends
depuis ce matin tous les observateurs
dire oui mais enfin bon ça finalement
c'est passé pas si important ce qui va
être important c'est son interview ce
soir dans le jt de tf1 20 heures certes
mais si on veut capter la france qui ne
va pas regarder ce jt est cette france
certainement s'abstenir c'est
intéressant d'utiliser les résolutions
et alors sur vous l'avez évoqué le fait
de
de singe et le général de gaulle c'est
complètement c'est un copié collé c'est
vrai qu'on regarde là l'image du général
de gaulle avec son micro l'appel du 18
juin on a exactement celle d'eric
zemmour voilà des décennies plus tard
donc bien sûr c'est voulu sauveur de la
france eric zemmour parle jamais de
guerre mais en choisissant cette
symphonie de beethoven plus que le
discours d'un roi y avait aussi
diplomatie qui s'endettaient qu'ils en
étaient servis c'est aussi la guerre
entre la france et le saint empire
romain germanique qui avait inspiré à
beethoven mais il y pense à cela cela
eric zemmour qui fait par hasard si on a
quelques années
sur le choix des images et donc
évidemment c'est ce champ lexical sans
jamais prononcer le mot de guerre qui
est employé par le polémiste et
maintenant le candidat écouter
puis des décennies nos gouvernants de
droite comme de gauche nous ont conduits
sur ce chemin funeste du déclin et de la
décadence
droite gauche ils vous ont menti nous on
dissimuler la gravité de notre des
classements ils vous ont caché la
réalité de notre remplacement voilà donc
pourquoi youtube déjà finirait avec ça
et le meilleur support pour ce type de
déclaration parce que cette déclaration
déclenché chez nous des émotions et des
émotions négatives
la peur l'anxiété
l'égoïsme et ce sentiment d'un danger
qui est vraiment à nos portes et donc
pour eric zemmour s'est effectivement je
suis d'accord avec vous ultra efficace
en techniques de communication après il
faut voir quel public il a réussi à
cibler alors dont on va voir vous
reprendre un autre extrait de la vidéo
d'eric zemmour où il glorifie la france
du passé est extrait on a que le son et
je vais vous expliquer pourquoi juste la
presse on écoute
vous vous souvenez du pays que vous avez
connu dans votre enfance vous souvenez
du pays que vos parents vous ont décrit
vous vous souvenez du pays que vous
retrouvez dans les films ou dans les
livres
le pays de jeanne d'arc et de louis xiv
le pays de bonaparte et du général de
gaulle le pays des chevaliers et des
gentes dames alors l'énumération elle
dure encore pendant pendant des dizaines
de secondes mais nous on n'a gardé que
son pourquoi parce que tout simplement
la gaumont le journaliste clément
l'anneau de propriétaires menace
d'attaqué eric zemmour il a utilisé par
exemple des images du film jeanne d'arc
sans autorisation bref il ya un côté
amateurisme chloé ridel mais je veux
dire il veut se présenter veut devenir
président de la république il n'est pas
capable de s'assurer des droits d'auteur
avant de diffuser cette vidéo de
candidature fin je dire tout est dit
rien à ajouter mais par rapport à
l'extrait que vous venez de diffuser
agir cette énumération le pays des
gentes dames et damoiseaux fossé c'est
clownesque en fait quand on est présent
la république on n'est pas conservateur
de bibliothèque rien pour prendre des la
france dans le nouveau siècle mais
puisque c'est qu'est ce que c'est que ce
à quoi oui je partage le point de vue
mais le pendant du discours sur le
déclin ça a été montré par parra ou le
jardin c'est la nostalgie c'est l'âge
d'or c'est la france amif là et cette
nostalgie
marché une partie des français ça mais
c'était avant ça fait chier de le dire
mais ça ne suffit pas pour passer du
statut du constat du statut du polémiste
à une mue en candidat après
présidentielle qui va qui pourrait
gagner qui va qui voudraient gagner qui
va proposer une offre programmatique
complète qui font montre d'un grand
professionnalisme parce que ça n'arrive
pas à gérer une campagne comme vous
dites des droits d'auteur quid de la
france dans un contexte où l'attend
d'expertisé très fort chez les français
c'est là qu'ils avaient rita limiter
cette mue il doit faire 2 au cours des
prochains jours mais j'étais c'est à
dire qu'il n'est pas assez entouré eric
zemmour il est finalement assez seul
dans sa salle à oui c'est un amateurisme
total on est tout à fait d'accord et
c'est peut-être ce qui le distingue de
ses prédécesseurs ou même de ses
homologues étrangers parce que eric
zemmour je suis certaine qu'il après
exemple aussi sur ce qu'il s'est passé à
l'étranger c'est à dire qu'il n'a qu'à
regarder ce qui s'est passé en italie en
italie un mouvement politique le
mouvement 5 étoiles est née et s'est
développée et a accédé au pouvoir a
dirigé d'italie puisqu'on a eu un
premier ministre italien issu de ce
mouvement grâce aux data grâce au
numérique aux ingénieurs à la data qui a
bien sûr à un moment donné a été
transposée sur le terrain dans la rue
mais ça eric zemmour le sait sauf que
qui était avec beppe grillo en italie
c'était oui oui bien sûr c'est sa vie ni
a été ensuite bien sûr a été sud ce
mouvement il s'en est servi il a même
créé la bête ce qu'on appelle la bête en
italie c'est un système numérique de
marketing c'est tout bête hein
déclaration elle et elle était partagée
il y avait
les mécaniques notamment oui de bonnes
connaissances des algorithmes opérateurs
qu'ils seraient démultipliés lapointe ce
qui était génial c'est qu'en fait beppe
grillo toutes les propositions qu'il
faisait c'était juste issue de des
propositions des débats de la bande en
fait des de la communauté qu'il avait
fédéré ville donc en gros il prônait les
dix propositions qui avait eu le plus
d'engagement le plus de like le plus de
commentaires et puis lancer ses
propositions dans son programme et donc
forcément le public à des ré ça
s'appelle le marketing politique l'offre
se calque elle a demandé mais je reviens
quand même sur cette histoire d'image
dont eric zemmour n'avait pas les droits
alexandre de wikio c'est s'il n'est pas
vraiment entouré pour se lancer dans une
campagne présidentielle c'est quand même
l'énorme point faible de sa campagne je
rejoins ce qui a été dit et il ya une
énorme différence avec trump avec beppe
grillo avec boris johnson beppe grillo
était entouré de génie de l'informatique
là je pense que c'est des francs tireurs
qui sont habiles sur les réseaux sociaux
mais qui sont effectivement amateurs et
pour ce qui est de trump boris johnson
en angleterre trump avait le parti
républicain boris johnson le parti
conservateur l'argent qui va avec c'est
pas du tout le cas d'eric zemmour il
faudrait vraiment qu'ils qu'ils
élargissent qu qu'il ouvre un peu sa
campagne parce qu'il pourra pas le faire
qu'avec une bande de jeunes dynamiteur
qui moi un certain talent pour dynamiter
mais je pense qu'on peut pas gagner seul
et sans se professionnalise et
maintenant j'aimerais répondre à ce qui
a été dit en balayant un peu le côté
ridicule moi je suis patient je pense
que la france est une patrie littéraire
une patrie historique et faire appel à
cet imaginaire là je pense que ça peut
être au contraire la bibliothèque c'est
l'homme des livres c'est leur chanson à
mitterrand faisait la même chose je
pense que ça peut être au contraire
assez assez payant et je crois que la
politique c'est aussi l'art de
s'inscrire dans un grand récit ce qu'on
a un peu oublié avec une politique de
plus en plus gestionnaire et ça a été la
force de maquereau ou de mélenchon en
2010 est d'avoir su faire ça alors que
la droite pour le coup s'est empêtrée
dans une politique gestionnaire et
comptable est donc là moi je pense que
c'est un vrai point fort d'eric zemmour
de capable de se mettre en scène un
récit en mode réponse cohérente hameau
de réponse oui évidemment que tous les
cas les présidents qui
qui ont été élus avec cette espèce de
supplément d'âme littéraire et ça avait
convoqué une sorte enfin se doter d'une
sorte de
voile à 2 sur moral intellectuel
convoqué à littérature et c'est très
important bien sûr mais là la façon dont
s'est fait dans le clip je maintiens que
ces clowns ex et brunet ce qui est
ridicule et que ça me convoque que la
nostalgie les belmondo les brigitte
bardot les gentes dames et damoiseaux et
c est que c'est parce que c'est le
moteur sur lequel ils prospèrent la
nostalgie alors sur dance dans la danse
dans l'hérault de derry 0 il n'ya pas
joséphine baker il a il l'a pas cité
elle est entrée au panthéon cet après
midi une femme libre noir résistante
bisexuels qui avait adopté des enfants
de toutes religions qui étaient aux
côtés martin luther king lors de son
grand discours pour les droits civiques
à washington en août 63 joséphine baker
qui émet plus la france que beaucoup de
français voilà ce que disait l'une de
ses filles elle s'appelle marianne
marianne becker c'était ce matin sur rtl
on écoute c'était une femme qui avait de
multiples facettes et qu'elle a toujours
aimé la france au delà de tout
d'ailleurs c'est pour ça qu'elle m'a
appelé marianne et je pense qu'il faut
il faut pas oublier qu'elle était plus
française que certains français elle
avait adopté ce pays comme elle nous a
adoptés et je pense que son combat pour
la diversité
elle l'a souvent dit elle n'aurait pas
pu le faire dans un autre pays que celui
ci voilà joséphine baker qui entre en ce
moment même au panthéon à la cérémonie
se déroula à quelques mètres
d'ici puisque on est on est au sénat
évidemment voilà l'une des lunes des
premières photos de cette cette
cérémonie joséphine baker eric zemmour
c'est ces deux visions de la france qui
s'oppose une certaine façon c'est ça
alors c'est pas seulement hasard du
calendrier qu'est ce que vous diriez là
dessus louis sans doute ces deux visions
de la france je pense que le calendrier
d'eric zemmour si c'était moi la
concomitance avec l'entrée au panthéon
tellement mérité de becker que ce soit
et je suis d'accord le débat mais
surtout le vote puisque le vote c'est
après demain le champion et l'air va
être la championne air va être désigné
samedi en début d'après midi et c'est
vrai que quand on va avoir une
incertitude une inconnue de l'équation
président scène qui va enfin être levé
et pour eric zemmour il importait d'une
part de mettre fin à cette mauvaise
passe je dirais pas en fait sondagière
il a un seul qui est quand même
extrêmement élevé entre 12 et 15% selon
les enquêtes il continue à puiser à deux
sources électorale une source de droite
est une source d que du d'extrême droite
ou du rassemblement national mais
commençait à marquer des points parce
qu'il y aura dans un contexte où la la
gauche est à un niveau historiquement
bas dans toutes les enquêtes on est à
peine un quart de gauchy à ce bloc de
gauche il ya le bloc mac rognant où il
ya un bout droite et ya une sorte il va
y aura une sorte de compétition entre le
rn le candidat de qualitair eric zemmour
pour pouvoir essayer d'être le
réceptacle de ce peuple de droite qui
est quand même sensible je répète au
constat qu'il a fait notamment celui
très dure de la france qui disparaît et
du sentiment de dépossession alors
justement on va en parler tout de suite
avec cantat calmait
merci de nous rejoindre quand un bon
soir vous avez rencontré des sénateurs
heller
à l'occasion de leur réunion de groupe
aujourd'hui voilà l'occasion de leur
poser la question de votre débat thomas
effectivement zemmour enfin un candidat
officiellement qu'est ce que ça change
et bien pas grand chose selon l'ancien
ministre sarkozyste et actuel
soutiennent va et pécresse roger
karoutchi écoutez sa réaction ce matin
depuis un mois on imaginait bien qu'il
allait être candidat il le clamait sans
dire mais enfin bon non je pense que
maintenant il va devoir répondre à un
certain nombre de questions est par
définition le côté seulement polémiste
ne vole plus suffire
l'élève qui ne semble pas
particulièrement gêné thomas les
derniers événements de la campagne il
dit placement qu'on peut dire chaotique
et d'eric zemmour à marseille redonne de
l'oxygène à la droite écouter jérôme
bascher il est soutien de xavier
bertrand c'est une surprise c'est plutôt
lui qui avant son calendrier pour passer
ses dires de la mauvaise période et les
gestes déplacés et qu'il ait pu
commettre non c'est un non-événement
cette campagne c'est plutôt un événement
pour lui c'est à dire essayer de se
rattraper aux branches alors qui
dégringole certains aient l'air sur 100
sont sur une ligne de crête lorsqu'il
évoque eric zemmour parce que certains
sont d'accord avec la plupart de ses
thèses et avec beaucoup de choses qui a
pu porter avec sa candidature est donc
ils ne veulent pas non plus renier et le
constat fait par le polémiste écoutez à
ce propos jacqueline eustache brinio
c'est elle qui avait porté par exemple
le texte ici au sénat sur l'interdiction
du voile des accompagnatrices scolaire
c'est vrai que les sondages aujourd'hui
le mettre face à la réalité de ce qu'il
est c'est-à-dire quelqu'un qui a
effectivement
animé le débat activer le débat mais ça
suffit pas pour être un bon candidat et
peut-être que les français s'en rende
compte
mais les élèves espèrent que le soufflé
est mort tombe que la bulle médiatique
fasse pschitt notamment grâce à la
séquence de leur congrès vous en paliers
ferris xo qui s'ouvre ce jeudi on a mis
les amplis sur zemmour vous allez voir
que les amplis vont être débranchées
assez peu assez rapidement espère à
notre micro sénateurs l air merci
quentin et frédéric effectivement vous
vous en parliez ça peut quand même eux
la candidature officielle de zemmour est
ce que d'après vous ça peut jouer sur le
vote de voilà on sait qu'il ya eu
beaucoup de nouveaux inscrits on est à
pratiquement 150 mille votants est ce
que ça peut jouer sur le vote c'est
certain je vais faire un scénario et
qu'ils voteraient peut-être ciotti en se
disant ciotti va pouvoir faire le pont
avec ses mots alors exemple il convient
d'être extrêmement prudent car on est
sur un cas assez unique où le corps
électoral est complètement inconnu je
parle des 140 gm il avait rang ont peut
faire l'hypothèse oui que ça peut
favoriser un eric ciotti qui a été à
l'aise dans les débats qui a qui colle
beaucoup au discours zemmourien et aux
aspirations des adhérents qui sont
toujours plus à droite que les
sympathisants qui sont même plus à
droite que l'ensemble des français il
peut aussi avoir un regard sondage est
sûre en ce moment c'est plutôt xavier
bertrand qui apparaît le mieux placé à
droite pouvoir faire ce match face à mel
macron et face à l'art in le pnr et eric
zemmour mais c'est très compliqué
d'imaginer ce qu'elle serait la psyché
et les pensées d'un corps électoral
aussi restreint aussi inconnu puisque
comme vous dites à côté des 75 mille
adhérents canal historique il ya eu
presque 100 % du corps électoral qui a
été ajouté oui bien vous pouvez le faire
mais si vous aviez la liste cécile
pas laisser sécher a l'impression qu'on
oublie aussi un détail qui est quand
même juste fondamentale il faut qu'il
ait les 500 parrainages
putatif de jeu qu'on continue à parler
de la bulle médiatique du phénomène est
mort et c'est ce qui m'a décidé oui ou
non
son arrivée au premier tour et
potentiellement du fait qu'il bouleverse
le scrutin c'est l'obtention des 500
parrainages et pour l'instant il ne les
a pas oui mais lui reste il reste pas
mal de temps c'est fin mars à ses 5 mars
la date et jusqu'en mars sur les idées
parce qu'on peut aussi analyser la
séquence de ces dernières semaines sur
le plan des des idées alexandre ii
vecchio est ce que finalement eric
zemmour a pas déjà en partie gagné cette
bataille à droite quand on a quand on a
assisté aux débats aient l'air depuis
plusieurs semaines oui j'entends qu'il
serait une bulle médiatique il est
possible que sa campagne face au dhj et
il est possible qu'il ait pas ses
signatures pour des raisons
d'amateurisme même si je pense que si
les républicains sorte un candidat comme
xavier enfin capable d'être au second
tour et lui les deux noms parce qu'il
abaisse le seuil de de qualification au
second tour donc il pourrait y avoir une
alliance un peu contre nature parenthèse
refermée mais je crois que par contre
eric zemmour au delà de sa capacité à
créer le débat de ses talents de
polémiste il a surtout porté des idées
qui sont profondes en france frédéric
dabi là dit
elle sont majoritaires peut-être dans le
pays si on prend sur la question de
l'immigration maintenant la question
d'un terme qui était polémique comme le
grand remplacement donc les angoisses et
l'angoissé existentielle il est toujours
mais est entré dans le vocabulaire
collectif et une partie des français le
match va faire parler de bouleversements
démographiques mais une partie des
français aujourd'hui ne vois pas de
problème à parler de franc de
remplacement c'est un petit
jeu on va faire le débat mais en tout
cas je sens que le
la dépossession
culturelles économiques démocratiques
parfois que ressentent les français est
une réalité comme elle est une réalité
dans beaucoup de démocraties
occidentales c'est pour ça qu'on a eu le
phénomène trump c'est pour ça qu'on a eu
le phénomène de johnson par exemple
celle ci on va pas pouvoir la contourner
en fait à eric zemmour c'est le nom
d'une inquiétude et je pense qu'il
s'agira pas seulement de dire c'est un
clown et de fer de lance et de
l'antifascisme d'opérette à un moment ou
un autre et maupas zemmour il faudra
répondre à cette inquiétude mais c'est
effectivement l'enjeu qu'il peut sur la
table et c'est le pari qu'il fait de
répondre à l'attenté d'une majorité
selon lui de l'électorat et ça on le
verra bien parce que pour le moment
aucune enquête
marine le pen a fait 35% l'on croit ou
sur le bon tour de l'élection
présidentielle la dernière fois il ya eu
un abstentionnisme très importants dont
il ya une grosse force proportion des
français qui sont pas contents de
l'offre politique ou alors propose
qu'ils ont le sentiment qu'on les a
jamais consulté sur un certain nombre de
questions notamment sur les questions
d'immigration et d'intégration et ça je
pense qu'on pourra pas mettre la
poussière sous le tapis éternellement ça
veut pas dire du tout eric zemmour on va
gagner ou que marine le pen va gagner
mais je crois que la démocratie c'est
prendre en compte quand même nous les
aspirations populaires il faudra que le
vainqueur quel qu'il soit tente de
répondre à cette angoisse existentielle
l'abstention c'est le thème de notre
second débat merci de nous faire le lien
chloé ridel sur cette droitisation
des idées ou de l'opinion française
aujourd'hui est la relation dans tout ça
parce que si vous voulez eric zemmour
est un homme de l'uby donc
c'est une sorte de féminisation de la
société comme il dit qui serait la
source de notre affaiblissement en
espoirs dans une violence inouïe mais
bon on a que comme ça ses discours
grand remplacement tout ça ce sont ce
sont des lubies si vous voulez qu'il
nourrit en prenant des faits divers en
prenant des images et avec une
information qui est toujours biaisées en
un sens et c est moi je regrette que le
débat public et au temps perdu en
qualité et en débat sur des faits
objectifs
je suis d'accord avec vous sur le fait
que oui cilly 35% des français votent
pour marine le pen oui 35 plupart des
français ont une angoisse vis-à-vis de
l'immigration et même la marine le pen
je vous signale trouve que eric zemmour
est d'une brutalité
c'est celle qui le dis
c'est qu'on sent dans les sondages je
pense que mais attendez on sait que
c'est un fait banal mais on peut
contester quand même jetés renard dans
le droit des populations pour tester ses
idées il ya pas deux il n'y a pas de
souci là-dessus mais dire que que c'est
le fruit d'un fantasme ou je pense que
c'est c'est un peu facile et ce sera
dommage pour la qualité du débat on peut
ne pas être d'accord avec son diagnostic
donc pour reconnaître que son diagnostic
est partagé au moins par une partie de
la subvention son ca essentielle à la
responsabilité médiatique sera
fondamental parce que sans les médias le
phénomène et moore et son ascension dans
les sondages à mon avis n'aurait pas
existé donc il faudra ensuite voir moi
je pense que si si c'est pas vraiment ça
aurait été un autre soir était le pen ou
un autre ça existait dans d'autres pays
donc attribué sa aux médias du reste on
voit qu'ils essaient de contourner les a
trahis
c'est peut-être au fait amplification au
delà du diagnostic d'eric zemmour moi ce
qui me frappe c'est que il ne match pas
complètement avec les attentes des
français qui pour l'instant sont très
plurielle pendant cette pré campagne
présidentielle il ne dit pas un mot de
la situation sanitaire dans un contexte
où malheureusement on va peut-être
connaître une campagne de nouveau figée
glacé par le retour d'une épidémie à
l'éducation bien tableau de bord mais
c'est assez intéressant qui est vraiment
qui vient de sortir le secteur éviter
pour paris match et sud radio
effectivement on regarde notamment les
conversations des français les premiers
thèmes c'est que là on est clairement
alors c'est la vérité mais on est
vraiment vraiment sur ce
qui est intéressant c'est qu'il ya
encore quinze jours la crise sanitaire
était complètement mise à distance
l'inquiétude était au plus bas mais là
les cinq premiers sujets sont des sujets
sanitaires aussi bien le débat en
autriche la troisième dose la campagne
de vaccination et pour la première fois
la montée en puissance de l'intérêt pour
la campagne présidentielle recul oui
alors qu'en temps normal on est sur une
logique de crescendo jusqu'à l'échéance
finale doivent donc savoir que c'est un
peu conjoncturel sais pas combien de
temps ça va durer et messages et sert
pour l'instant je pense que ça peut pour
l'instant ne favoriser que dans une
logique des faits drapeau le président
oui d'ailleurs il était depuis 10 mois
extrêmement stable en popularité au
couteau de 40 % ils gagnent 4 points sap
a une importance fondamentale mais ça en
dit long sur peut-être un nouveau récit
est un nouvel épisode de sa précampagne
dans ce tableau de bord l'action des
manuels macron approuvé par 43% des
français effectivement c'est un cetain
+4 j'aimerais qu'on parle de ce fameux
plafond de verre le candidat eric
zemmour peut-il remonter dans les
intentions de vote dans les prochaines
semaines l'une de ses faiblesses et le
niveau de détestation qui le provoquent
je propose de réécouter ce qu'il faisait
gaël sliman sur ce plateau c'était mardi
dernier quand on approche des 50% de
rejet on est dans des zones très rouge
très dangereuse mais jean marie le pen
qui était le champion du rejet pouvait
atteindre les 55 56 % de rejet au plus
fort de ses saillies
marine le pen était la championne du
rejet sur votre palmarès du rejet
pendant très longtemps alors on a eu des
pics de jean luc mélenchon quand il
disait la république il est encore aux
agents très haut et très haut jean luc
mélenchon mais eric zemmour avec ses 61
% c'est quelque chose de très important
ce pour sa grave
il y là il a gagné si j'ose dire trop
quel point j'ai plus de mémoire mais sur
le rejet tout en ne gagnant pas de
points sur l'adhésion pour comparer les
deux il ya douze points de rejet de plus
sur eric zemmour que sur marine le pen
et gail simone qui nous donnait une
liste de qualificatifs je vais en citer
quelques-uns enfin ceux qui sortaient en
prioritairement dans ses enquêtes
extrême droite agressif raciste
dangereux dangereux ça me semble très
important comme qualificatif l'on tombe
veut accéder à la prise en main
république misogyne et c'est ça c'était
avant l'épisode du e
du doigt d'honneur à marseille qu'à pu
le servir je pense est ce que frédéric
amis vous diriez que c'est rédhibitoire
ça pour atteindre le second tour de la
présidentielle ce niveau de coopération
plutôt pas la détestation et peut être
mauvaise pour le second tour on connaît
l'adage de charles pasqua qui lui même
avait repris une phrase de guy mollet
qui était au premier tour on choisit au
deuxième tour on élimine et c'est vrai
que des marine le pen et jean luc
mélenchon d'eric zemmour qui ont un
niveau je reprends pas ce terme de
délation mais de très mauvaises fées
opinions peuvent pâtir d'une logique
d'élimination en revanche le premier
tour c'est une logique de race en deux
rassemblements quand on voit qu'il
arrive à capter à un électeur fillon sur
cinq qui là des piques dans telle ou
telle catégorie sociale
quand on est entre 12 et 15 ans fait
aujourd'hui avec un ticket d'entrée pour
ce second tour qui s'assemblent est sans
doute plus bas qu'en 2017 ce n'est pas
complètement réduit toi en tout cas
c'est vrai que la présidentielle c'est
une sorte d' alliage entre un programme
une vision et une incarnation et c'est
vrai que l'incarnation et mot est quand
même très très amis les skis et ce qui
est plus inquiétant pour lui c'est une
1re j'ai presque automatique dans une
partie très importante de l'électorat
féminin ça c'est quelque chose que je
trouve plus dangereux n'a pas ces styles
d'un premier toit oui
le terme dangereux qui revient dans les
qualificatifs associé à eric zemmour et
je rapproche ça de sa réaction à
marseille de cet échange de doigt
d'honneur avec une passante est ce que
son entrée en campagne peut gommer un
peu une partie de
de ces qualificatifs parce que là il va
jouer je pense qu'on peut s'y attendre
et vous direz peut-être qu'il va faire
dans les prochains jours il va jouer la
carte de la présidentialisation le plus
possible enfin c'est encore faut-il
qu'il y arrive ça j'en doute très
fortement le qualificatif dangereux oui
c'est très préoccupant et je partage
d'ailleurs ce constat en prison la
réplique c'est quoi c'est quand même
quelqu'un qui représente la france à
l'international parle de fierté de la
france et je pense que les français on
encore quand même de fierté est ce
qu'ils ont envie qu'on soit représentée
à l'international par un type qui fait
des doigts d'honneur à ses opposants qui
éructe sur les plateaux de télévision
qui divise en permanence les gens n'ont
donc je lis à un moment on n'est pas on
est en train de bien en prison de la
république on n'est pas si vous voulez
en train de jouer à ce fait il faut
arrêter de jouer à se faire peur comme
ça et je crois que si vous voulez la
capacité de notre mode de scrutin à
faire qu'un candidat qui est rejeté par
61% des français arrive deuxième dans le
classement des intentions de vote peu ou
prou quand même un problème il ya un
problème dans la pondération
je me permets de parler du mode de
scrutin parce que par ailleurs je
préside l'association qui s'appelle
mieux voter et qui défend un nouveau
mode de scrutin qui est le jugement
majoritaire et qui vraisemblablement
pondère à la fois le rejet l'adhésion
béland différence il ya un vrai problème
avec notre mode de scrutin qui favorise
les candidats clivant c'est à dire comme
zemmour qui a un socle d'adhésion fort
qui lui permettrait peut-être d'accéder
au second tour alors même qu'il est
rejetée par une majorité de français
donc on marche sur la tête on a un mode
de scrutin qui ne reflète absolument pas
l'opinion des français je voudrais qu'on
en termine avec un dernier extrait
de cette vidéo d'eric zemmour c'est
vraiment vraiment les phrase de
conclusion de son discours
nous les français nous avons toujours
trio c est tout vive la république et
surtout bible
vive la république et surtout vive la
france évidemment tout cela n'est pas
anodin il est plus français que
républicain alexandre ii et dieu sait ce
qu'il veut nous faire passer comme
message menaçant même façon on peut être
les deux
mais je pense que c'est surtout une
réponse à la classe politique qui ait pu
depuis des années
à adresses des brevets de république a
lié ce coup de new republic and i se
réfère à des valeurs républicaines qu on
peine parfois à définir effectivement je
pense qu'il l'entend plus que défendre
des principes abstraits défendent d'une
france charnelle d'où les images de
belmondo de brigitte bardot les images
faisant référence à l'histoire de france
nous eric zemmour veut se poser comme le
candidat de l'identité nationale et il
n'y en eut mené en t il une identité qui
est incarnée et qui ne reposent pas
seulement sur des principes abstraits
après commence par vive la république
donc je pense qu'il n'est pas opposé à
ces principes là edel est ce que ça vous
choque vous savez avant cette
formulation est maladroite monsieur
zemmour n'a pas le monopole de la france
il faut arrêter lui c'est là franchement
c'est la france noir et blanc enfin je
veux dire brigitte bardot belmondo mais
encore une fois on les adore mais c'est
absolument pas à la hauteur des enjeux
ils ne parlent pas d'écologie or la
france c'est aussi la nature si son
patrimoine naturel que serait la france
sans ses champs de vignes sans ses
champs de blé ce ne serait plus non plus
la france donc je dire il n'a pas le
monopole de ce qu'est la france est de
dire vive la république et surtout vive
la france mais qu'est ce que ça veut
dire quoi disons que là il est très
clivant et c'est vrai que si il vraiment
il veut briguer l'elysée il va falloir
qu'ils les largesses à tout petit peu
son discours pour inclure les femmes
c'est quand même la moitié des français
peut-être les les gens de couleur on
peut les appeler parce que lui il
s'adresse à des hommes blancs qui sont
situés à droite de l'échiquier politique
c'est quand même un segment très petit
de l'électorat qui existe qui est votre
plus que la moyenne qui votent on est
tout à fait d'accord il est acquis avec
actifs passion et qui peut vraiment se
reconnaître dans la candidature d'eric
zemmour mais je pense que ces troubles
que c'est trop court qu'est ce qui peut
faire dans les prochains jours donné
quelques acquis là il va faire le donc
il fait il est un plan média qui a très
institutionnel c'est à dire que je pense
que quand il n'y aura de toute façon
être actif sur les réseaux sociaux ça et
alors sus pour la petite anecdote il
n'était sûr aucun réseau social l'hiver
dernier c'est à dire que cette passion
soudaine pour les réseaux sociaux elle
est vraiment artificiel mais il sera un
plan média tout à fait traditionnelle
c'est-à-dire qu'il va aller dans
activement à 20 heures ensuite il va
faire l'émission politique de france 2
et il fera normalement une matinale sur
service public de la radio
donc il va faire le parcours que tout un
chacun tous ses concurrents font parce
qu' il ne peut pas faire autrement c'est
à dire qu'il ne peut pas être que dans
la communication disruptive il n'a pas
encore les moyens pourquoi parce qu'il
n'a pas une popularité est une sa
notoriété est acquise mais la popularité
n'est pas assez large je te fais
d'accord et en plus il a dimanche qui
arrive à un grand meeting
au zénith c'est 4000 à 5000 places
va-t-il le va-t-il de remplir ces
tunisiens qui se posent et surtout quand
on va sans doute faire il va sans doute
faire un discours d'une heure et demie
ou pourra pas rester que sur les
constats c'est un moment très très
important ça avait lancé la campagne de
françois hollande en 2012 le meeting du
bourget à 2007 la porte de versailles
pour nicolas sarkozy c'est un moment de
vérité beaucoup plus qu une intervention
dans une émission de télévision quel
qu'il soit et il va ne pourra pas rester
que sur la rupture la distinction avec
vie vous avez la république et surtout
depuis la france il va devoir faire
quelque chose qu'il n'a pas fait dans
cette entrée en campagne il a pu se
parler de la france qu'il n'a pas parlé
des français oui il n'a pas encore parlé
aux français pas exactement française
est ce que vous direz oui je trouve
qu'il a surtout parlé de la france la
france qui disparaît il a parlé des
français qui se sentaient déposséder
maîtrise méprisait qui on a menti il
était sur une voie passive si je puis
dire vis-à-vis de son rapport avec les
français il va devoir maintenant montrer
un chemin et s'adresser directement à
eux et dans ce cadre là le plus dur
commence parce qu'il n'a quasiment
jamais fait oui l'image qui reste de son
rapport aux français c'est son doigt
d'honneur puisque ça c'est un rapport
direct oui alors il se sera nommé
c'était intéressant quand vous parlez de
paysages tout à l'heure
effectivement
il n'a pas été peut-être encore assez
dans le pays profond eric zemmour
notamment voir cette france périphérique
l'électorat populaire que marine le pen
pour l'instant au concert votre est
largement et je pense qu'ils auraient
tout intérêt voilà à s'adresser à eux et
le fait de faire des grands médias comme
tf1 même s'il a fait des chiffres
importants sur les chaînes d'info ça
peut lui permettre aussi de parler à un
public un public plus large encore
faut-il qu'ils allaient conscience de ce
besoin là il ya à garder des fossés kido
de je trouve de son début de campagne
c'est qu'elle était parfois un peu en
sol et je pense que si il faut qu'ils se
réconcilient avec le terrain à marseille
c'était plutôt ratée de ce point de vue
là à suivre dans les prochaines semaines
évidemment merci à tous d'avoir
participé à ce débat bientôt